how are you doing nick i'm doing well uh
i'm in
los angeles uh just kind of getting back
into work for the first time
starting up on a few things and it's
kind of weird but you know it's it's the
new
the new world have you been able to
enjoy extra time with the family during
the pandemic especially now that we're
approaching
holiday season yeah i mean it's hard to
find
the silver lining in all this but i
think we have to we
lose our minds um and that's the thing
is is i've been able to stay
real creative and and uh just you know
working on a kind of number of things
whether it's music stuff or film and
television development and writing
uh but then the biggest upside of all
this has been that time at home which
uh me and prairie wouldn't have had you
know had this all happen as
busy as our schedules have been in the
last couple years um so
you know that has been an upside and and
just for a little while kind of planting
our roots but she's
she's been back at work the last couple
weeks uh shooting
matrix four i know i was like girl you
got to give me some dates on this
this movie but she didn't he hasn't even
told me anything so i'm i'm
i don't know i don't know yet i'm at the
watch like everybody else yeah sworn to
secrecy now i gotta say you have been
making great use of your time in
quarantine and congrats on your new gig
you are an executive producer on
netflix's new series dash
and lily i really want to meet you and
think about you all the time
so what are you doing here go find her
what if i'm not the girl in his head
i sort of shifted my focus over this
last year
um to the writing and development stuff
i've been doing so over the next couple
months though i'm sure there'll be a
number of
announcements about projects that i'm
working on but it's it's really become a
passion for me and
uh i love you know i love telling
stories and as a lover of
tv and film it was kind of a dream to be
able to shift my focus into that side of
things
that is so awesome now do you and pre
ever talk shop at home because she's
also executive producing
some stuff over at netflix so do you get
any advice from her on the ep in front
of things
for sure i mean i think both of us spend
a lot of our time
you know bouncing our ideas off each
other and and
having that that support kind of built
in at home is is uh
such a an amazing thing and we're
actually working on a number of things
together as well so
it's kind of a family business at this
point i love it nick that's some great
stuff
now a little spoiler alert here for
folks that are going to watch this
i was so shocked to see a jonas brothers
cameo in there
and then you my friend making your
little appearance be known
in there as well and providing some love
advice to the characters
you gave your own experience of your
proposal to pre
saying that you had to get deep and
vulnerable in that moment so can you
take us back to that moment and maybe
how your own advice has maybe helped
shape
your love story today i think for any
person that proposes to their person
and you know that even as as confident
as self-assured as you can be walking
into that situation it's still a little
nerve-wracking
um and it should be because it's a
pretty big
big stuff right there pretty big
question um
but you know i think it was it was fun
to be able to to
to say that it was it was really
different because i'm sitting there
going okay here i am
not much older than these these uh
young actors but here i'm giving this
advice made me feel kind of like oh
but i'm getting older um and it's it's
happening
you're an old man now nicarooni hardly
um but yeah you know it it was a nice
little scene and
and hopefully those that need to hear
that message hear it and
um feel inspired to go and
do whatever they need to do
[Music]
i need you christmas out now jonas
brothers just released a new song we are
so happy for it
this i feel like is christmas in and of
itself for the jonas family because
you're married joe just had a baby
kevin's got his beautiful
bunch frankie's in the mix your parents
are good
i mean do you just feel like you this is
a wonderful time right now for your
family
yeah for sure i wish we could all be
together but you know that's that's so
many
i think families uh wish and dream at
the moment
i'm grateful everyone's healthy and
happy and you know
we've all been very fortunate but uh
looking forward to a time when life gets
back to hopefully some kind of
version of normal and we can spend some
time together
nick have you been able to gush over
that new sweet baby miss willa
i have and it's it's you know
joe and sophie's thing to speak about or
not but she's uh she's
she's the best oh i love that